ein symbol des american way of life
verrottet im amazonasdschungel
ist das ein filmset was zum teufel macht
das hier
gigantische betonklötze versteckt in den
wäldern polens
wer wollte sich hier wo vorschützen
ein hoch gesicherte todesstreifen der
sich quer durch deutschland zog
um den fortbestand des landes zu sichern
mussten sie es zu einem gefängnis machen
und eine kuriose anlage die sich gegen
die gesetze der physik stimmt
ingenieure aus aller welt kommen hierher
um dieses ding in aktion zu sehen
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht doch wer waren ihre erbauer
wie wurden sie errichtet und warum
wurden sie wieder aufgegeben
[Musik]
mitten im brasilianischen amazonas
becken am ufer des rio tapajós steht
eine geisterstadt konserviert wie in
einer zeitkapsel
früher war das 10.000 quadratkilometer
große gelände ein quasi souveräner staat
geführt von einem us industrie waren
[Musik]
menschen stellen sie sich vor sie fahren
diesen brasilianischen fluss hinunter
und plötzlich stehen da diese
verlassenen gebäude und dann auch noch
ein original
amerikanischer hydrant
[Musik]
eine ziemliche überraschung mitten im
brasilianischen dschungel auf landhäuser
im camp coach teal mit swimmingpools zu
stoßen was für ein kontrast
hoch über der siedlung thront ein 50
meter hoher wasserspeicher wie man ihn
aus us amerikanischen kleinstädten kennt
[Musik]
das sieht aus wie ein filmset und man
fragt sich moment was zum teufel macht
das ding hier
wer hat diese kopie einer us kleinstadt
mitten ins amazonasbecken verpflanzt und
sie dann wieder verlassen
die gründung der siedlung geht zurück
auf die industrielle revolution anfang
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
die autoindustrie erlebt weltweit einen
boom der jedoch durch das britische
kautschuk monopol ausgebremst wird
leidtragende sind vor allem die usa doch
henry ford der erfinder des bezahlbaren
autos hat den festen willen das monopol
der briten aufzubrechen
denn wenn er profitabel sein will muss
er ausreichend kautschuk zu bezahlbaren
preisen finden
[Musik]
geschäftsmann er baut autos autos
brauchen reifen aber kautschuk ist teuer
also sagte sich ich zahle doch keine
mondpreise für kautschuk lieber umgehe
ich die zwischenhändler und bau mir
meine eigene kautschuk fabrik
schließlich wächst das zeug im
brasilianischen urwald
für gerade einmal
125.000 dollar kaufte ford ein 10.000
quadratkilometer großes areal im
brasilianischen urwald
genug platz für eine riesige kautschuk
plantage und seine retortenstadt ford
länder
henry ford hatte den ruf nicht zu
kleckern sondern klotzen
deswegen war auch niemand überrascht
dass er nicht nur eine fabrik baut
sondern sagte nein ich baue gleich eine
ganze stadt
die stadt wurde gebaut um eine kautschuk
plantage zu betreiben es ging darum eine
riesenzahl von diesen bäumen zum
pflanzen und abzuernten um kostengünstig
an kautschuk für reichen zu kommen
[Musik]
1928 wird aus der vision realität
mit deutschen maschinen baut ford in
brasilien die größte kautschuk plantage
der welt fort wenn die ford hofft so die
gestiegene nachfrage nach seinen autos
bedienen zu können
foto anja war ziemlich groß dafür dass
es so abgeschieden liegt es hatte mehr
als 2000 einwohner einen tanzsaal und
ein krankenhaus als hätte man eine
amerikanische kleinstadt mitten in den
brasilianischen dschungel verpflanzt
ziemlich visionär
raimondo des susanne sporrer lebt immer
noch in portland er kennt sich hier aus
vor allem mit der fabrik dem ehemals
pulsierenden herzen der stadt
hier drin war eine lagerhalle ein
sägewerk und eine werkstatt
auch die elektrizität für die stadt
wurde hier erzeugt hier war das herz von
allem
ford länder etwa viermal so groß wie das
saarland bietet seinen arbeitern die
gleichen annehmlichkeiten wie den ford
mitarbeitern in den usa
dennoch stößt dieser us außenposten im
dschungel auf skepsis der amerikanische
lebensstil und die arbeitsweise sind den
einheimischen fremd
henry ford der seine mustersiedlung
niemals selbst besucht wollte dass
amerika seine jugend im amazonas nach
baum doch er baut nicht nur eine stadt
fort gründet einen unabhängigen staat
dessen einziges ziel die kautschuk
produktion ist
wie man latex aus kautschuk räumen
gewinnt ist interessant tagsüber steigt
er im baum auf die arbeiter müssen sehr
früh aufstehen solange der latex noch
erreichbar ist sie sitzen den baumann
und ernten
der flüssige latex wird mit verdünnter
säure gemischt und gewinnt zu einem
kautschuk teig
anschließend wird überschüssiges wasser
mit einer walze herausgepresst
heute ist vom kautschuk boom vergangener
tage nichts mehr zu spüren doch damals
sollten hier in portland tausende tonnen
kautschuk produziert werden
henry ford hatte mit der brasilianischen
regierung ausgehandelt dass fortan der
quasi ein eigenständiger souveräner
staat ist ohne jede einmischung das war
wie eine blankovollmacht die stadt so zu
regieren wie er wollte
das ist ein lehrstück für kulturelle
ignoranz
denkt dass das was in amerika
funktioniert sich eins zu eins nach
brasilien übertragen lässt
aber der american way of life kommt im
amazonasgebiet nicht gut an
es herrschte militärische disziplin
alles war extrem streng und kontrolliert
die leute in fort lauderdale einen
alkohol trinken sie sollten sich um ihre
gärten kümmern square dance tanzen und
bestimmte sachen essen das war den
leuten alles total fremd und
überraschung die sache läuft schief
unter den einheimischen regt sich
widerstand
eigentlich hätte die retortenstadt mit
allem amerikanischen komfort ein
paradies für die belegschaft sein sollen
doch stattdessen empfinden die
einheimischen arbeiter das leben in fort
länder als unzumutbar
1930 eskaliert die situation
die arbeiter meutern sie zerschneiden
die telegrafen draht und jagen manager
und den koch in den urwald
das brasilianische militär musste
anrücken und die sache regeln die leute
hatten einfach die schnauze voll
[Musik]
letztlich rächte sich dass harter
regiment die leute im vorjahr wollten
einfach nicht nach diesen strengen
regeln leben
der naive traum eines amerikanischen
eagles im amazonasdschungel ist geplatzt
und auch die kautschuk plantage geht den
bach runter
der wald wurde gerodet aber man
versäumte gleich danach die kautschuk
bäume zu pflanzen
kautschuk bäume sind aber sehr anfällig
für krankheiten und genau das ist
passiert
[Musik]
ford versteht viel von autos aber nichts
von landwirtschaft in den tropen sein
leitungsteam im amazonasgebiet ist in
den usa hervorragend ausgebildet worden
aber spezialisten für den kautschuk
anbau hat er nicht fort versuch die
biologie zu industrialisieren endet in
der katastrophe
schon als er die kautschuk setzlinge
einpflanzen lässt ist der misserfolg
programmiert
henry ford scheiterte mit dem versuch
sich eine alternative kautschuk welle zu
erschließen die bäume wurden viel zu
dicht nebeneinander gepflanzt sie sind
aber anfällig für krankheiten und wenn
man sich zu dicht pflanzt sterben alle
die ganze sache war einfach nicht
richtig durchdacht und
dann kommt 1945 auch noch synthetisches
kautschuk auf dem markt der finale
todesstoß für ford länder
die 25 millionen dollar investition ist
ein mega flop
letztlich scheiterte hotline die ja
nicht nur an seinen restriktiven regeln
sondern auch an der ökonomischen
realität nach der erfindung des
synthetischen kautschuks gab es einfach
keinen grund mehr kautschuk zu pflanzen
[Musik]
1945 verkauft vor zenkel den
untergegangenen amerikanischen traum zum
schleuderpreis von
250.000 dollar an die brasilianische
regierung die überlässt ford länder sich
selbst
60 jahre lang bot die stadt vor sich hin
bis einige hundert einheimische die
vorteile einer fertig gebauten stadt
entdecken und sich in der us geister
kleinstadt niederlassen
wir haben die us kultur in jeden winkel
der welt exportieren aber nur weil die
leute das auch wollten und sich das
herauspicken was ihnen gefiel wir dürfen
aber nicht vergessen dass wir auch immer
wieder versucht haben anderen kulturen
die unsere aufzuzwingen wien fort lande
das war ein musterbeispiel für fehlende
kulturelle sensibilität und das sollten
wir nicht vergessen
[Musik]
fast 9000 kilometer entfernt mitten in
deutschland stehen die überreste einer
ganz anderen gigantischen anlage
nahe der sachsen anhaltinischen
kleinstadt hötensleben stößt man auf
panzersperren eine lange bröckelnde
betonmauer und einen streifen umgepflügt
der erde
eine sehr spezielle und besondere anlage
eine 3 meter vierzig hohe stacheldraht
bewehrte betonmauer zieht sich durch
einen breiten streifen grünland der mit
wachtürmen gespickt ist
es ist das grenzdenkmal hötensleben ein
mahnmal für eines der dunkelsten kapitel
deutscher geschichte
[Musik]
das jahr 1945 hitler deutschland hat den
krieg verloren und wird von den
alliierten siegermächten verwaltet in
den westlichen besatzungszonen regieren
england frankreich und die usa im osten
wie kommunistische sowjetunion
anfangs sind die grenzen zwischen den
zonen noch offene
1949 wird in der sowjetischen
besatzungszone die deutsche
demokratische republik gegründet
[Musik]
die westdeutschen erkannten die existenz
eines ostdeutschen staat zunächst nicht
an sie begingen absichtliche
grenzverletzungen und andere dinge um
die ostdeutschen zu provozieren
als die bundesrepublik am 26 1952 ihrer
souveränität erlangt eskaliert die
situation an der deutsch-deutschen
grenze
um ihre bürger an der republik flucht zu
hindern errichtet die ddr-führung eine
fünf kilometer breite sperrzone an der
grenze zur bundesrepublik der grundstein
für die teilung deutschlands ist gelegt
das meinte winston churchill als er
sagte dass ein eiserner vorhang quer
durch europa gefallen ist
eine fast 1400 kilometer lange
innerdeutsche grenze teilt das land in
zwei hälften die
grenzanlagen waren enorm sie reichten
von der ostsee in südlicher richtung bis
nach mitteldeutschland
an einigen stellen gab es kilometerweit
keinen einzigen baum damit flüchtende
keine deckung finden konnten
[Musik]
offiziellen bilden die grenzanlagen wie
auch die berliner mauer einen
antifaschistischen schutzwall der die
ddr vor angriffen aus dem westen
bewahren soll das ist aber reine
propaganda
[Musik]
es ging hier nicht um eine
verteidigungslinie auch wenn die
ddr-führung das behauptete genau wie die
berliner mauer richtete sie sich gegen
das eigene volk
das ddr regime regiert in praktisch alle
lebensbereiche seiner bürger hinein
die ddr ist trotz ihres namens nicht
demokratisch
[Musik]
es gibt keine freien wahlen keine
gewaltenteilung und keine reisefreiheit
vielmehr ist die ddr eine diktatur die
von der staatssicherheit gestützt wird
an die hunderttausend spitzel schnüffeln
im dienste der stasi sie bespitzeln ihre
nachbarn freunde oder kollegen und
bekämpfen oppositionelle oft mit
perfiden mitteln
viele ddr bürger wollen in die
bundesrepublik fliehen
eine massenauswanderung würde der
planwirtschaft der ddr jedoch enorm
schaden
die ddr beein autoritärer staat um ihn
am laufen und am leben zu halten hat man
das ganze land in ein gefängnis
verwandelt
[Musik]
hatte die ddr mit dem bau der
grenzanlagen begonnen im laufe der jahre
während der kalte krieg immer weiter
eskaliert wird auch die innerdeutsche
grenze immer weiter aufgerüstet
[Musik]
die grenzschutz anlagen wurden
schrittweise gebaut anfangs waren sie
noch relativ simpel und einfach doch je
mehr die spannungen zwischen ost und
west zu namen desto größer und
abschreckender wurden die grenzschutz
anlagen
susanne baumgartl und ihre familie waren
lange hinter diesen mauern eingesperrt
die sperranlagen bestanden aus zwei
zonen der äußere ein metallgitterzaun
war in ddr jargon feind werz gerichtet
neben diesen zaun waren panzersperren
oder ein kfz graben und davor ein
streifen ungepflegter erde um spuren
sehen und sichern zu können
[Musik]
seit 1968 gilt republikflucht in der ddr
offiziell als straftat wer erwischt wird
muss für bis zu drei jahre in den knast
trotzdem ist der abschreckungseffekt der
grenzzäune nicht so groß wie der
freiheitsdrang vieler ddr bürger
die sperranlagen werden immer weiter
verstärkt
zusätzlich zu den mauern gab es
wachtürme kommandoposten und
elektronische sensoren gestrüpp und
bäume wurden gerodet ganze dörfer
geräumt damit die grenzer einen freien
blick und damit auch eine freie
schussbahn hatte
die sperre anlagen werden zu einem
symbol der unterdrückung und zu einer
potenziell tödlichen falle für die die
sich zur flucht entscheiden heute ist
der todesstreifen zum größten teil
verschwunden nur in grenzmuseen kann man
die anlagen noch besichtigen es scheint
kaum noch vorstellbar wie damals die
grenze das land zerschnitt mitten durch
bauernhöfe kohleminen häuser und sogar
kirchen
ebenso wie die berliner mauer die stadt
in zwei hälften teilte wurden durch die
sperranlagen auch gemeinden durch die
grenze zerschnitten
häuser wurden zerstört
aus der innerdeutschen grenze wird eine
unüberwindliche und potenziell tödliche
festung als 1961 die berliner mauer
gebaut wird sind die ddr-bürger
endgültig in ihrem land eingesperrt
als die sperranlagen aufgerüstet wurden
wuchs auch die zone zwischen der grenze
selbst und dem sogenannten niemandsland
davor hast
es gab zusätzliche wachtürme und
minenfelder
immense ressourcen wurden mobilisiert um
den eisernen vorhang zwischen ost und
west so effektiv wie möglich zu machen
an der grenze waren etwa 30.000 soldaten
der grenztruppen der ddr stationiert sie
hatten den befehl jede flucht auch mit
waffengewalt zu unterbinden
dies ist der metallgitterzaun auf der
östlichen seite auf der innenseite ist
er elektrisch wenn jemand aus dem osten
flüchten wollte und den zaun berührte
wurde alarm ausgelöst
die ddr-führung sichert ihre grenzen
zusätzlich mit 1,4 millionen
antipersonenminen und 55.000
selbstschussanlagen dennoch gibt es
weiterhin mutige und verzweifelte die
die gefährliche grenze luft wagen
327 werden dabei getötet
hunderte menschen sind bei
fluchtversuchen gestorben sie wurden
erschossen sind auf linien getreten oder
wurden von hunden angegriffen
nicht nur zivilisten wollen den arbeiter
und bauern staat verlassen auch einige
grenzschutz soldaten waren den
gefährlichen grenzübertritt
25 werden dabei erschossen
um den 17 juni 1953
kommt es zu einer welle von streiks und
protesten die bürger der ddr fordern
unter anderem freie wahlen und
wirtschaftliche reformen der aufstand
wird von der sowjet armee gewaltsam
niedergeschlagen insgesamt sterben 55
menschen
um das regime zu stabilisieren baut die
sed danach den unterdrückungsapparat
macht weiter aus bis er schließlich fast
die gesamte bevölkerung erfasst
das jahr 1989 markiert das ende einer
epoche nach dem fall der berliner mauer
zerfällt auch der sogenannte ostblock
innerhalb weniger jahre
an die bilder vom fall der berliner
mauer erinnert man sich bei den anderen
grenzanlagen war es nicht ganz so
dramatisch
mit der wiedervereinigung deutschlands
wurden die sperranlagen und der
grenzstreifen nutzlos sie wurden
abgebaut auch in der hoffnung damit die
wirtschaft zwischen ost und west
anzukurbeln
fast an der grenzanlagen werden bald
nach der wiedervereinigung komplett
abgerissen
dabei fallen millionen tonnen bauschutt
an 45 jahre nach dem bau der ersten
sperrzone ist die innerdeutsche grenze
geschichte
[Musik]
heute sind die grenzmuseen mahnmale für
ein dunkles kapitel deutscher
nachkriegsgeschichte
und zugleich ist der ehemalige
todesstreifen inzwischen heimat für eine
vielzahl von tier und pflanzenarten
[Musik]
der erhalt von grenzanlagen mit
stacheldraht und wachtürmen ist eine
wichtige gedächtnisstütze für zukünftige
generationen damit sie die geschichte
der deutschen teilung nicht vergessen
heute sieht das alles nicht mehr so
eindrucksvoll oder gefährlich aus es ist
oft nur noch ein grünstreifen zu sehen
und ein weg doch man muss sich klar
machen dass es früher für jeden
flüchtling eine todeszone war
[Musik]
800 kilometer weiter östlich im
äußersten nordosten polens
in den wäldern der masurischen
seenplatte auf einen fast 250 hektar
großen areal steht eine ansammlung
seltsamer gigantischer betonklötze
man spaziert durch einen polnischen wald
und wie aus dem nichts stehen da
plötzlich diese riesigen betonklötze was
ist das
sie tauchen ganz plötzlich zwischen den
bäumen auf wer hat diese massiven dinge
gebaut
die fensterlosen gegangen und sind bis
zu 13 meter hoch und über 20 meter lang
welchen zweck dienten sie
[Musik]
die mauern sind so dick dass sie eine
apokalypse standhalten könnten aber
warum
wer hat diese gruseligen betonklötze
mitten in die wildnis gesetzt und warum
wurden sie wieder verlassen
[Musik]
für die antwort müssen wir die uhr fast
80 jahre zurückdrehen
im oktober 1940 hat die wehrmacht weite
teile westeuropas besetzt doch nach der
verlorenen luftschlacht um england muss
hitler die invasion großbritanniens
verschieden
stattdessen will hitler die sowjetunion
angreifen im juni 1941 gibt er den
befehl zum start für unternehmen
barbarossa
codewort für den überfall auf die
sowjetunion
eine der größten invasions streitmächte
aller zeiten macht sich auf den langen
weg nach osten um die truppen auch
versorgen zu können braucht hitler
militärbasen nahe der frontlinien eine
davon errichtet elbenwald vom energie zu
deutscher wald
hitler weiß dass er einen modernen
industriell geprägten krieg führen wird
also bauen seine leute die technologisch
fortschrittlichsten kommando und
kontroll posten die es im zweiten
weltkrieg überhaupt gab
eines dieser befestigten quartiere ist
das ukh mauer wald das hauptquartier vom
oberkommando des heeres
von mir erhalten die soldaten an der
ostfront ihre direkte befehle
das war eine voll funktionstüchtige
militärbasis die mit stacheldraht
minenfeldern und bewaffneten kontroll
posten gesichert war
im prinzip haben sie hier eine kopie der
berliner einrichtungen in den wäldern
gebaut
hitler hat hier seinen eigenen bunker
mit anlagen für den stab das heißt auch
wenn er nicht in berlin ist kann er den
krieg weiter führen und hat sein
nazireich fest im griff
der mauer wald liegt nur 20 kilometer
von hitlers bunkeranlage wolfsschanze
entfernt die bauarbeiten beginnen im
herbst 1940 um die anlage zu errichten
müssen hitlers ingenieure zunächst den
sumpfigen boden trocken legen und
hunderte bäume in den mücken verseuchten
wald fällen das bunkersystem ist
weiträumig im wald verteilt sollte der
feind einen der bunker entdecken bleiben
die anderen walter funktionstüchtig
damit wollte man das risiko minimieren
dass bei fallschirmspringer oder
bombenangriffen alles mit einem schlag
vernichtet wird deswegen wurden sie
verteilt
[Musik]
der militärkomplex erstreckt sich über
den gesamten monat
er ist unterteilt in drei bezirke namens
fritz brigitte stadt und quelle sie
beherbergen den generalstab den general
quartiermeister und alle
kommunikationseinrichtungen
alles war durchorganisiert und sauber
angelegt so als würde es hier um eine
bürokratische einrichtung gehen und
nicht um den knotenpunkt eines brutalen
krieges
wichtige einrichtungen sind in massivem
stahlbeton bunkern untergebracht während
armeeangehörige und personal in
einfacheren holz und stein baracken
leben
radek glitschig der aus der umgebung von
man nach kommt kümmert sich um die
anlage
man muss sich vorstellen dass hier
überall holzhäuser in der gegend standen
die mit plastik bäumen und netzen
getarnt waren sie wurden um die fassaden
herum aufgestellt auch auf den dächern
der bunker
die tarnung des mauerfalls ist extrem
ausgeklügelt je nach jahreszeit gibt es
passende kunststoff bäume im jeweils
passenden farbton
die bunker waren sehr gut befestigt was
diese monolithischen bauten aber
wirklich einzigartig machte waren die
räumlichkeiten die waren winzig so als
hätte man schon damals vorhergesehen
dass es irgendwann zu einer
militärischen katastrophe kommen würde
gegen die man sich schützen musste
die mauer der bunker sind sieben meter
dick und über meinem kopf sind noch mal
sieben meter beton
innen drin wird der bunker dann immer
enger
[Musik]
die räume sind sehr klein aber hier geht
es nicht um komfort
das wichtigste ist dass man hier mit
hundertprozentiger sicherheit einen
bombenangriff überleben würde
damit der feind die bunker gar nicht
erst findet wird im beton seegras
beigemischt dadurch wird das wachstum
von moosen begünstigt die den bunkern
einer natürliche tarnung gegen und das
seegras hat noch einen weiteren vorteil
das seegras durchzieht die äußeren
schichten des bunkers so dass der beton
nicht ab splittert
[Musik]
im sommer 1941 nehmen 40 generäle und
1500 stabsoffiziere quartier im mauer
wald zu dieser zeit gibt es auf dem
gelände rund 250 gebäude und 30 punkte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
traditionell sind deutsche
kommandostrukturen so aufgebaut dass es
einen general gibt er im auto oder im
panzer ins feld fährt um dort befehle zu
geben
unterstützt wird er von einem stabschef
und einer menge von stabsoffizieren dem
hauptquartier bleiben und funkkontakt
mit der armee halten während der general
die schlacht anführt
um seine männer bei laune zu halten hat
hitler in der tristen beton festung
sogar für ein freizeitangebot gesorgt
südlich bemerkenswert ist wie groß die
anlage war es gab 200 gebäude bunker
luftschutzräumen doch auch
annehmlichkeiten wie in einem kleinen
ferienort etwa ein kino oder ein kasino
und das alles praktisch direkt an der
ostfront
da der abgelegene bunker komplex weit
entfernt von großen städten und straßen
ist muss er sich zur not selbst
versorgen können
ein hauptquartier musste vollkommen
autark sein daher gab es hier eine
eigene strom wärme und wasser versorgung
das heißt man könnte hier auch ohne
nachschub für längere zeit überleben
[Musik]
mit einigen unterbrechungen verbringt
hitler bis ende 1944 insgesamt 800 tage
hinter den stahlbeton an der
nahegelegenen wolfsschanze in
den besprechungsräumen der wolfsschanze
weite hitler die offiziere in seine
pläne ein die fuhren dann rüber in den
nahen wald und setzten die befehle in
die tat um
von 1941 bis 1944 hat sich das
oberkommando des heeres im auwald sicher
verschanzt durch bitterkalte winter und
brütend heiße sommer doch dem
meterdicken mauern können den
zusammenbruch der ostfront nicht
verhindern
ganz gleich wie gut die offiziere im ukh
mauer wald waren sie konnten hitlers
unrealistische und größenwahnsinnige
ziele niemals erreichen
im herbst 1944 wird die wehrmacht in
einem aussichtslosen zweifrontenkrieg
verschließen die rote armee rückt im
osten unaufhaltsam vor im januar 1945
muss das oberkommando des heeres den
mauer wald schließlich kampflos
verlassen
die deutschen hatten keine andere wahl
als den sofortigen rückzug anzutreten
das ukh mauer wald wurde komplett intakt
zurückgelassen eine geisterstadt die
wehrmacht hat nur 48 stunden zeit um
star lance vorrückenden truppen zu
entkommen es bleibt keine zeit die
betonbunker zu sprengen
anders als die wolfsschanze wird der
mauer wald voll funktionstüchtig
hinterlassen
heute sind die beton monolithen in maur
wald weitestgehend in vergessenheit
geraten
dabei bilden sie bis heute eines der
größten erhaltenen bunker systeme der
nationalsozialisten in ganz europa
noch heute zeugt das ausmaß dieser
anlage vom treiben der nazis ganz europa
zu beherrschen wie viel zeit und mittel
sie für diese infrastruktur aufwendeten
um ihre militärische reichweite dadurch
zu erhöhen ist eindrucksvoll aber
gleichzeitig auch unheimlich
[Musik]
etwa 2400 kilometer weiter südwestlich
lebt das französische städtchen montag
[Musik]
die top ebene landschaft wird von einem
sechs meter breiten beton kanal
durchschnitten er ist 125 meter lang und
nur teilweise mit wasser gefüllt
es ist keine schleuse aber was ist es
dann
ingenieure aus der ganzen welt kommen
hierher der ort hat irgendwie etwas
hypnotisches etwas faszinierendes an
sich
der kanal selbst hat nur drei prozent
gefälle
gleichzeitig steigt das gelände auf
einer länge von 443 metern um 13 meter
an
das widerspricht jeder logik aber so
wurde gebaut
flankiert wird das gewässer von zwei
seltsamen fahrzeugen mit je acht reifen
sie sind mit einem 200 tonnen
metallgestänge verbunden an dessen ende
eine art schild angebracht ist
das ganze sieht furchtbar unpraktisch
aus aber irgendwie auch interessant
es erinnert an eine fantasie maschine
von jules verne wasser fließt dank der
schwerkraft nach unten und dann
plötzlich durch einen bestimmten
mechanismus wieder nach oben
was ist das für eine merkwürdige
konstruktion und warum wurde sie
aufgegeben
im siebzehnten jahrhundert wurde der
handel zwischen dem mittelmeer und im
atlantik über eine monatelange
beschwerliche reise entlang der
spanischen küste abgewickelt
schon zu kaiser augustus zeiten hatten
die römer davon geträumt die beiden
mehrere zu verbinden
seit 1666 wurde an den kanal zwischen
den meeren gebaut er durchschneidet
frankreich auf einer länge von 430
kilometern und soll den handel beleben
[Musik]
doch bei montech sind auf einer länge
von fast zweieinhalb kilometern ganze
fünf schleusen was zu staus und
verzögerungen führt
mit kanal schleusen kann man ein boot
anheben oder absenken so dass man auf
dem wasser selbst hügeln überwinden kann
schleusen gehören zu den größten
errungenschaften der technik geschichte
das problem ist nur dass man sie jedes
mal füllen oder lehrern muss und das
kostet viel zeit
[Musik]
christian otto von der französischen
wasserstraßen verwaltung ist für die
region west languedoc verantwortlich
die versuchsanlage wurde gebaut damit
die kommerzielle schiffe hat die fünf
schleusen mit hilfe dieses neuen systems
umgehen konnte
drei jahrhunderte nachdem der bau am
canal de deux meer begonnen wurde kam
der französische ingenieur wer auf die
idee diese einzigartige vorrichtung zu
bauen das sogenannte wasser keil
hebewerk
das französische wasser keil hebewerk
war eine absolut revolutionäre
alternative zur herkömmlichen schleuse
das schiff fuhr zunächst in den unteren
bereich des kanals ein da schwamm das
boot in gerade genug wasser und dann
schoben die staaten triebwagen diesen
wasser keil samt boot die betonrinne
hinauf
absolut verrückt aber irgendwie auch
brillant
[Musik]
in der 1974 fertiggestellte anlage
können selbst voll beladene lastkähne
einen höhenunterschied von 13,3 metern
bewältigen
das prinzip des wasser kein hebewerks
ist eigentlich ganz einfach wenn du was
aus deinem verstopften spülbecken
rauskriegen willst du das wasser einfach
mit der hand raus dabei gibst du den
wasserspiegel in der tiefe an und
schiebt es über den rand auch beim
wasser quell hebewerk startest du unten
und bewegt das wasser die gefälle rinne
hinauf du nutzt das gleiche prinzip in
dem du das wasser nach oben schießt und
so einen wasser kalt schafft der tief
genug ist für ein boot oder ein lastkahn
um darauf zu schwimmen
umfasst 1500 kubikmeter wasser und einen
vollbeladenen lastkahn den fahrern
hinauf zu schieben braucht man energie
viel energie
der antrieb ist 1000 ps starker
zwölfzylinder motor
treibt einen generator an der genug
energie erzeugt und das triebfahrzeug zu
bewegen
das tolle am wasser keil hebewerk ist
dass man genau sieht wie es funktioniert
alles passiert direkt vor seiner nase
ein kann fährt in einen kanal ein und
hinter ihm geht die schleuser zu
sobald dieses wasserdichte tor sich
hinter dem schiff senkt entsteht ein
wasser keil abgeschnitten vom rest des
kanals das schiff schwimmt auf diesem
wasser teil der dann mitsamt dem schiff
von dem triebwagen den kanal hoch
geschoben wird
diese beiden kraftvollen lokomotiven an
beiden seiten des kanals rollen dann
langsam an den rändern der betonrinne
bergauf der schieber drückt dabei das
wasser den kanal hinaus und nimmt den
kann mit
mit gemächlichen viereinhalb stunden
kilometern schieben die triebwagen den
wasser keine vor sich her die schubkraft
der maschinen beträgt 63 tonnen
aber wie wird das ganze gesteuert
hier steht der wagenführer und bedient
den triebwagen er muss für das rangieren
einen rundum blick haben das umsetzen
selbst wird mechanisch kontrolliert vor
allem mit diesem regler hier das ist
eigentlich alles
20 minuten dauert die fahrt auf dem
wasser keil hebewerk das ist 45 minuten
schneller als der weg über die schleusen
treppe
zwei triebwagen auf beiden seiten des
kanals fahren auf dem damm den hügel
hinauf wenn sie oben ankommen öffnet
sich das tor und das schiff kann seine
fahrt fröhlich fortsetzen
[Musik]
tausende boote mit einem höchstgewicht
von bis zu 250 tonnen sind auf diese
weise auf dem wasser keine bergauf
gefahren
mir gefällt wie einfach das technisch
gelöst wurde aber die technologie stammt
aus den 70er jahren
diese monströsen dieselmotoren die die
boote langsam den kanal hochschieben das
passt nicht so richtig ins 21
jahrhundert
die triebwagen und konstruktion des
kanals das wassertor das verhindern soll
dass das wasser einfach nach unten raus
läuft all das kann zu erheblichen
problemen führen
insgesamt 35 jahre lang tun die
triebwagen in montag ihren dienst dabei
schieben sie am die 10.000 boote bergauf
und legen insgesamt rund 4000 kilometer
zurück 2009 jedoch besiegelt ein
motorschaden fürs erste das schicksal
der kuriosen anlage weltweit gibt es nur
zwei wasser keil hebewerk die jedoch
beide im augenblick stillgelegt sind
nicht jeder ingenieurs geistesblitz ist
dauerhaft praxistauglich und das ist
vielleicht ein beispiel dafür
die anlage ist aus der zeit gefallen
aber wenn heutzutage kanäle noch die
hauptverkehrsadern wären gäbe es
vielleicht hunderte solcher hebewerk
mangelnder auslastung und
reparaturkosten von rund 4,2 millionen
euro führten letztlich dazu dass das
wasser keil hebewerk aufgegeben wurde
heute zieht die eigenwillige anlage
touristen und technik freaks aus aller
welt an
möglicherweise wird sie in den nächsten
jahren saniert
auch wenn sich die erfindung letztlich
nicht wirklich durchgesetzt hat für die
ingenieure ist sie doch eine inspiration
nicht mit tunnelblick durch die welt zu
laufen sondern dinge auch mal anders
anzugehen und dadurch etwas
außergewöhnliches zu schaffen
[Musik]
einst waren sie die speerspitze des
technologischen fortschritts heute sind
sie verlassen inmitten dieser
verfallenen bauten sind die echos der
geschichte hörbar sie könnten von krieg
und terror aber auch vom erfindergeist
und vom menschlichen streben nach
fortschritt
[Musik]